peu
je me baladais sur l'avenue le coeur
ouvert à l'inconnu j'avais envie de dire
bonjour à n'importe qui n'importe qui ce
fut toi je t'ai dit n'importe quoi
il suffisait de te parler pour pas pris
oise et
au change
m
on changeait les airs
au soleil sous la pluie
à midi les changer tu m'a dit j'ai
rendez vous dans un sous sol avec des
fous qui vivent la guitare à la main du
soir au matin alors jeté accompagner
on a chanté on a dansé champs-elysées
aux champs elysées
tel perche non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez les palans la cruelle toulouse
histoire de faire battre ils furent
l'écart nationale et que ceux ci sert
d'exemple à tous ceux que le diable et
garde le droit chemin
petit à l'école à la place de crayon et
la benelli
en guise de cravates et cordes de l'ain
ne vous étonnez pas
premier cri
vide avoir fait mourir leur maman de
chacun
c'étaient les dames
les salles est parfait
il s'était débrouillé pour rattraper la
rage lévis mais le docteur qui faisait
les vaccins
été contaminés
r les gens du voisinage
amusant pas les morts dont lui accusé
les chiens avec tata katabola les dalton
c'étaient les dalton
tagada tagada y avait personne
et de valeur des hommes
[Musique]
un conseil mon ami avant de les croiser
embrasse à ta femme serment la main
vite sur la vie
il va taper rassurer
franche et toi la gorge est de 3,6
c'étaient les dates
le canada a plus personne
et
la justice payer
comme tous les journaux togolais tu m'as
senti pressenti américain qui s'éternise
et avide d'argent ils se libèrent mai
sheila prix carry trade est encore plus
bête que méchant en somme
les datas
tagada tagada ya plus personne
[Musique]
je les plus près dans l'ornière
l'essai blanche brebis quand j'ai
demandé
les sabots vrai chat de maddie
s'écroulait dans la rosée qui vend les
bergères
mais quand j'ai
je voudrais giroud l'air aussi elle m'a
dit
m
la colline
check
je suis plus
j'ai attendu
jamais
[Musique]
m
à la foire du village jours
elle souffrirait
en six ans
et qu'à chaque fois qu'elle pas seul
bien
mais elle est passée tout en me montrant
ces jolies dents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis maire
jamais
je suis
[Musique]
oh
mais m
mahdi dalé sublet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir
hop
[Musique]
or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
e
salut c'est encore moindre
sa venue
comment tu vint le temps
même un très long l'un d'eux l'un
'sans j'ai pensé
à toi fougères
naviguer
et je le sens fatigué
[Musique]
chez moi
un peu café j'ai une histoire à toi
il était une fois quelqu'un
tu viens
il est
à part du prêt
il s'élève
[Musique]
salut
c'est encore
[Musique]
ouais
maison j'ai pensé
à
non
baba
- pour le
[Musique]
tu sais j'ai beaucoup changé
je m'étais fait des idées
sur toi
sur moi sur vous
c'est le fun
les
faux
tu
e
je me suis un
souvenu
le thème
pas comme eux
je
[Musique]
c'est encore
salut
alors
danser
[Musique]
tu sais ça
je n'ai jamais été aussi heureux que ce
matin là nous marchons sur une plage un
peu comme celle ci c'était l'automne un
automne où il faisait beau une saison
qui n'existe que dans le nord de
l'amérique
là bas on l'appelle l'été indien
mais c'était tout simplement le nôtre
avec ta robe longue tu ressembles à une
aquarelle de marie laurencin
et je me souviens je me souviens très
bien de ce que je te dise la pala bien
non et un siècle
tu as une éternité
[Musique]
où tu voudras quand tu voudras ils ont
ça me va encore
lorsque
on sera là
toute la vie
sera pas seul à pas
aux couleurs
thé indien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je suis très loin de ce
matin d'automne et c'est comme si
j'étais lui je pense à toi
ou étude que ses études
est-ce que j'existe encore pour toi
je regarde cette vague qui va atteindre
à jamais la bulle tu vois comme elle je
reviens en arrière comme elle je me
couche sur le sable je me souviens je me
souviens des marées hautes du soleil du
bonheur qui passait sur la mer il ya une
éternité passé il ya un an
on y va où tu voudras quand tu
[Musique]
non ça me va encore
lorsque
moore sera
toute la vie
ce sera pareil sort
[Musique]
oula
non
m
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
samoa
je
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si tu n'existais pas
dis moi pourquoi j'existerai
pour traîner
dans un monde
neuf sans toi
sans espoir et sans regret
[Musique]
et si tu n'existais pas
je serrais d'inventer l'amour
comme un pain
qui voit sous ses doigts
mettre les couleurs
les jours et qui
si tu n'existais pas
dis moi pour qui j'ai xistera
des passants
que
et si tu n'existais pas je ne serais
qu'un point
plus
dans ce monde
qui vient
et qui va je me sentis
d
je remets
joint
mais toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si tu n'existais
témoin comme angers
mr m
je pourrais
en blanc
mais
le site
quoique
[Musique]
le secret
la vie
pourquoi
simplement
rés
c'est beau
[Musique]
m
mais c'est trop
soit
et moi pourquoi jésus
histoire
pour traîner
deux sans toi
sans espoir et sans
[Musique]
à toi à la façon que tu as d'être
façon que tu as des fins
as tu es mon temps
difficile
la poussée
tu es
à celle que tu es encore souvent
at on passait à fait se fait à tes
anciens prince charmant
à la vigne
adam nuit là
mal éteinte
retour de la chance à l'entendre il
viendra
qu'il ressent
à la fois 3
allez
dans tuer
deux ans
mais colère sans savoir pourquoi
un messi lancé un à dix ans quel
que ce soit
autant que j'ai passés se cherche
au khalife est une honte tu te
aux défauts que je des cachets
de baladin à la vie
à l'ennui
à l'été
retour de la chance à l'enfant qui
viendra qui nous ressemblent rats qui
sera à la fois toi et moi
à nous
au soleil
à l'avenir
en présence sur tout
à la santé de 7
une peine qu'il s'en fout
un aux espoirs et
monsieur
un autre proche un premier rang
à la santé de ces millions d'amoureux
qui sont en
[Musique]
à la façon que tu
rabat
façon que tu
à des montants
la spéciale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les matins il acheter ni ressenti
pains au chocolat
la boulangère lui sourit il ne la
regardez pas
hélas
et pourtant elle est très belle
les clients ne voyait qu'elle
elle il faut dire qu'elle était vraiment
très croustillant aux tantes ses
croissants
et mme rêver mélancolique le soir d'un
syndicat asso jaune à distance il est
payante
voilà tout
ne savais pas
hélas
[Musique]
de foot où les nuages
les peintures
il
m
ne savait
c'est
le
ce pas lui on voyait un aveugle être
offert son bord
et la fille qui n'était pas raid à
chaqra des lunettes à l'élu de son coeur
dans l'auberge de
maguette les débats y a
ja
dans la boulangerie en fait un soir on
m
et
boutons non quelles étaient leurs
né
et deux
union sont nés des tas de petits gosses
ya peu comme papa
quand va donc parmi les brioches se
remplissant les poches de petit pain au
chocolat
là
[Musique]
m
je dois m'en aller je n'ai
bene les carènes attend depuis que je
suis mais
mm
j'attends
sur l'engin
chose que j'aimais
cela
n'est ce pas
le chaque fois
l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais
je ne peux là
et je
[Musique]
6 7 1
je le sens
les cycles de 13 les sirènes
il s'en faut de l'argent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je te
si genève
[Musique]
sans assumer
oui je cap
de la mer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
si cette même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui précipite le
les sirènes
vous chantez sens
pour la chanson
[Applaudissements]
et vous
c'est ça
d'ici là
[Applaudissements]
lulu vendait ses toiles jacques ont
plongé dans un bistrot péter guth pélem
moi j'étais for what he gets
l'écart au caire on ne faisait rien on
sait faire les poches pour ce pays
vieux tacots
fleury sur le capot qui rêvait de
provence et qui mourut
fontainebleau
on allumait une cigarette
et c'était la fête le 14 juillet il
j'ai un copain de trop
y avait moins de nuit sans guitare
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on est
qu'est ce qu'on s'en foutait qu'est-ce
qu'on était
et boum
les quatre murs
tout près à s'écouler
[Musique]
bardet
on allumait une cigarette ou salut
et c'était là
ensuite
copains
straw dans l'équipage
il a fait moins de nuit sans guitare que
deux
sans pain
on appelle
qu'est-ce qu'on était
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout
[Musique]
sienne a mis les voiles et j'accepte
un bistrot
pour andré bois 2
je ne suis plus fort
un spectre
les impôts
qu'elle cherche du boulot
j'ai changé de guitare
j'ai gardé gains
cette terre guim
un chaude
du fonds
de là
seul
l'équipe à jojo
on allumait une cigarette
salut
et c'était là
1 comme pas un
dans l'équipage hall
[Musique]
il y avait moins de nuit sans guitare
sans pain
on partage et où est
qu'est ce qu'on est
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout
[Musique]
en sabre
je pense à toi
[Musique]
suite
- samoa
[Musique]
mon idée
c'est une plateforme d'acier
[Musique]
non
pétroliers
où tout est noir
le ciel est là
[Musique]
sa peur tout
l'essai
[Musique]
leur peur
vieux
ap ap
bien
[Musique]
seul
mais
à
je pense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
il tente pas
[Musique]
je pense à toi
je me baladais sur l'avenue le coeur ou
belrad inconnu j'avais envie de
bonjour à n'importe qui n'importe qui ce
fut toi je t'ai dit n'importe quoi
il suffisait de te parler pour
apprivoiser aux champs elysées
oh
[Musique]
on change les airs
au soleil sous la pluie à midi à minuit
il ya tout ce que vous voulez nouveaux
champs elysées tu m'a dit j'ai rendez
vous dans un sous sol avec des fous qui
vivent la guitare à la main du soir au
matin alors jeté accompagner on a chanté
on a dansé et l'on a même pas pensé à
s'embrasser aux champs-elysées
aux champs-elysées
on se l'est
sous la pluie à midi
à minuit il y à tout ce que vous voulez
vos champs elysées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier soir deux inconnus et ce matin sur
l'avenue deux amoureux tout étourdi par
la langue
et bonne étoile à la con comme un
orchestre a vu le corps tous les oiseaux
du point-du-jour chante l'amour aux
choses
aux champs elysées
au soleil
sous la pluie à midi
il est
tout ce que vous voulez aux champs
elysées
au chant d'ailés
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
aux champs elysées
sous la pluie à miner
ah mais oui à tout ce que vous voulez
aux champs elysées
m
[Musique]